[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
je ne sais pas si nous sommes 66
millions de procureurs comme le dit le
président de la république mais nous
sommes assurément 66 millions de
scientifiques de médecins qui savons
tout sur le virus sur le vaccin
comment s'épargner le coronavirus on va
parler justement de science mais on va
parler plutôt des espaces dans cette
émission on va parler aussi de la grève
puisque mardi il y aura une grève
générale dans la fonction publique est
ce que c'est le moment dans un pays qui
se prépare au confinement de faire grève
on parlera aussi de politico parlera de
caricatures et pour en parler philippe
quelques bonjour bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente de l'université de versailles
saint quentin vous êtes le directeur
adjoint du latmos et vous êtes à
l'origine de duvet excuse at qui est
parti dimanche
après quelques péripéties
météorologiques ça y est il est il est
dans l'espace il tourne on va en parler
justement de de base à cet événement
quand même français de d'envoyer un
satellite dans l'espace
en plateau jean charles lajoie denis
bonjour bonjour je suis content de voir
enfin le visuel de vision plutôt qu'aux
visiophonie la vision influence père
keller goûter de vous voir donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle est elle voulait pas me
croire
bonjour vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versailles
j'ai oublié de dire jean charles zone
que vous êtes éditeur
on dirait un mot de votre dernière
publication de jean-françois parce que
le seul témoin en tant qu'espace en
sibérie ci vers l'iss les glaçons et
puis nous sommes aussi en visio avec
josé cache un bonjour oui bonjour
patrice bonjour à tous alors vous êtes
directeur d'école à montigny et avec 7
avec vous qu'on va aborder
le premier thème pourquoi la grève de
cette grève qui s'annonce pour mardi la
cedh une grève générale de la fonction
publique qui est des qui est annoncé et
qui va toucher notamment l'enseignement
à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
je sais qu'elle sait qu'elle est quel
est le but au fond de cette grève
pourquoi cette grève très simplement
très simplement vous avez un adage que
vous qu on connait tous qui dit que
faire et défaire c'est travailler mais
quand on passe son temps à imposer à
mettre en pratique des directives qui la
plupart du temps sont inapplicables avec
la réalité du terrain quand on a des
propos qui sont contradictoires qui sont
souvent infondées et et bien tout cela
fait que aujourd'hui vous avez le corps
enseignant qui est essentiellement
peuplée de mécontentes exaspéré
décourager fatigue est inquiète
et tout cela sans avoir un soupçon de
considération pour tout ce que nous
avons fait jusqu'à présent et tout ce
que nous aurons encore à faire voilà en
quelques mots les raisons qui nous amène
aujourd'hui à faire à faire cette grève
l'objectif est de revendiquer un plan
d'urgence un plan d'urgence face à
l'enjeu sanitaire actuelle d'une part
mais aussi dans le but de pouvoir
assurer ses fonctions de service public
d'éducation quand vous dites y'a pas de
reconnaissance or on a eu quand même
plutôt l'impression avec justement quand
les gens se retrouvent fine et la
première fois que ils n'ont pas pu
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école qu'ils
avaient une sorte de grand respect pour
les enseignants justement parce que ils
ont compris la difficulté de leur métier
c'est de cette reconnaissance n'a pas
duré votre votre avis alors la
reconnaissance de qui la reconnaissance
de qui parce que déjà des parents ça
jusqu'à présent heureusement que nous
travaillons en concertation avec les
parents des parents sont très
respectueux de tout ce que nous avons
mis en place jusqu'à présent et ils sont
également très respectueux des consignes
qui leur ont été passées dans le cadre
du protocole sanitaire
mais enfin aujourd'hui on constate que
nous avons une hausse de près de 30%
chez les élèves et près de 40% chez les
adultes une hausse de 2,2 de personnes
qui sont positives au co bid et c'est
véritablement ça qui nous inquiète la
wii alors c'est à dire qu' il faut faire
un peu une différence entre ya des
revendications un peu général notamment
salariales dans cette grève vous vous
allez suivre la grève vous n'êtes pas
forcément d'accord avec toutes les
revendications notamment des syndicats
vous votre votre motif de grève si je
peux dire c'est la situation sanitaire
c'est ça c'est quoi faire face à face à
face au virus dont les écoles notamment
on a des revendications syndicales enfin
des revendications salariales qui sont
mises en avant dans le cadre de cette
grève là moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
avoir des revendications salariales
étant donné le contexte c'est un peu
indécent
maintenant ce que nous nous revendiquons
essentiellement c'est c'est comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est sur le plan
sanitaire c'est à dire avoir un accès
prioritaire la vaccination pour les
personnels de l'éducation nationale qui
souhaite bien évidemment c'est une
campagne massive de tests pcr dans les
écoles c'est aussi et surtout un
équipement en masques chirurgicaux à
usage unique
on a aujourd'hui des propos
contradictoires entre le port des
masques en tissu qui fait polémique ou
une fois on dit que les masque en tissu
pose problème et puis
dans les heures qui suivront nous
explique qui a pas de problème par
rapport à ça et puis ce qu'on revendique
également c'est une sont des règles en
fait des règles doivent être mises en
place des règles de cas contacts au sein
de l'éducation nationale qui doivent
être les mêmes que dans le reste de la
société tout simplement
et puis et l'harmonisation des règles de
fermeture des écoles en cap kloster
c'est une cacophonie aujourd'hui ce qui
se passe on a des situations qui sont
extrêmement disparates d'un département
à l'autre
certaines écoles sont fermées après un
cas contacts qui concerne en un seul
animateur tandis qu'une autre bas restée
ouverte après 20 cas positifs qui sont
adhérer donc c'est tout ça qui dès
qu'ils expliquent aujourd'hui le le
ressenti qu'on peut avoir par rapport à
ça
concrètement ça veut dire que par
exemple vous manquez de masques alors de
mon école on manque de masque on nous
fait des dotations de masque en tissu
qui depuis le départ
d'accord il a dit c'est bien de vous
annoncer que jusqu'à la fin de l'année
on serait encore dotées de masques en
tissu on ne sait pas aujourd'hui qu'elle
est
quel type de protection on est en
capacité d'avoir avec ses masques en
tissu on revendique tout simplement vous
avez les entreprises qui mettent en
place des protocoles et qui fournissent
leurs employés en masque pourquoi dans
l'éducation nationale on pourrait pas
être bénéficiaire de masques jetables
comme c'est le cas un peu partout des
masques et la priorité pour les
enseignants pour le pour la vaccination
c'est ce que vous demandez ce sera en
demande
on demande des masques des masques pour
les enseignants on demande une gratuité
de masques pour les élèves et on demande
à être considéré en fait comme
personnels prioritaires dans le cadre de
la vaccination
je voulais réagir oui oui c'est une
priorité assez sûrement très bien et
très physique mais enfin les enfants
sont on ne sait pas ne veut pas en
danger s'est passé par là s'il ne paraît
pas que les enseignants en collège et en
en école soit vraiment les personnes les
plus à risque du monde quoi donc après
encore une fois faire grève pour avoir
du masque en tissu là ok adhérents a dit
qu'il fallait plus de tissu mais la
médecine a dit que rien n'était prouvé
que le tissu c'était peut-être bien donc
on va pas faire face si les enseignants
se met à faire grève pour pour la
qualité du masque je dirais ont fait
grève tous les jours parce que comme on
ne sait toujours pas quel est le bon moi
je sais c'est sans fin donc est juste
super mines là dessus moi j'aurais aimé
que quitte à ce que des enseignants se
mettent en grève
il a une petite pensée pour
l'enseignante qui vient d'être balancé
par mediapart pour avoir eu des paroles
sur l'islam etc et que là tout le monde
s'en fout visiblement je laisserai plus
importants de masques en tissu que le
ces pauvres choses différentes
il ya un moment il faut choisir ses
priorités
nous sommes sommes en plus important de
défendre c'était cette enseignante que
de savoir sous un masque en tissu ou
s'il faut la gratuité du masque en
papier qu'on a c'est vrai qu'il a fait
je rebondis sur ce que vous venez de
dire que quand vous êtes au coeur du
système
effectivement je pense que nous n'avons
pas les mêmes priorités
il ya un constat aujourd'hui et quand
quand on voit comme quand on a des
incertitudes sur sur les moyens qui sont
mis à disposition
il me semble que le contexte actuel
justifie le fait qu'on soit le plus
prudent possible par rapport à certaines
choses donc je vous rappelle quand même
que la en l'espace de 24 heures on a
quand même 268 cas qui ont été avérés
chez les enseignants on à 1680 40 où on
a trois cent soixante dix classes qui
sont fermés sur l'ensemble de la france
on a une plus grande propagation qui
s'avère dans les écoles primaires on a
47 établissements scolaires qui ont été
fermés si vous estimer aujourd'hui que
nous ne sommes pas nous n'avons pas
compliqué ce type de choses j'en suis
bien désolé mais je permettez moi de
vous dire que lorsque vous enseignez
auprès des enfants à longueur de temps
qu'on vous annonce que l'école est
prioritaire et les enseignants ne sont
pas pour moi c'est un vrai combat
philippe gate voulait terminer là dessus
non j'ai très peu de compétences ses
désirs et de masques
moi je crois qu'effectivement le corps
s'était renseigné les souvenirs que j'ai
est et il demande à être globalement
valoriser ça c'est clair parce que
surtout là avec cette époque où cela
étant la gestion de crise puisqu'on est
dans ce geste une crise c'est toujours
compliqué donc il faut que tout le monde
essaye de gérer au mieux donc que plus
il ya des initiatives locales et que
chacun se prend en charge le chef je
pense parce que finalement on n'en sait
pas grand chose mais c'est vrai que les
les
vous êtes directeur d'école des écoles
des pompes des villes
est-ce que ses parents des pardons ah
non non je vous laisse venir votre
question dans ces cas les écoles des
plantes des municipalités dont les étals
des l sont gérés par les écoles
dépendent de l'éducation nationale j'ai
réparé mais si méritée est-ce que c'est
pas aux municipalités
ça ne serait pas aux municipalités après
tout de vous procurer les masques dont
vous avez besoin plutôt que quel état
mais les municipalités elles ont déjà
fait le nécessaire sur un certain nombre
de choses et notamment en termes de gel
hydroalcoolique et au delà de ça ce on
travaille on travaille systématiquement
en collaboration avec les municipalités
et heureusement
heureusement qu'on a leur appui et leur
soutien pour mettre en place tout le
protocole maintenant je crois qu'à un
moment donné quand vous avez les
décisions ministérielles qui sont prises
au niveau de l'éducation nationale s'est
petit à l'éducation nationale de
pourvoir aux besoins qu'on a dans les
écoles de systématiquement met ça sur le
dos des municipalités d'accord alors il
ya une question qui risque de se poser
dans quelques dans quelques jours on
parle beaucoup d'un nouveau re
confinement la question des écoles va
être posée et on entend beaucoup de
discours qui est de dire justement la
situation dans les écoles n'est pas la
même que celle dans les collèges ou dans
l'est dans les lycées c'est à dire que
les enfants de
de 13 14 ans sont plus sujets à avoir
attrapé le virus ils sont peut-être plus
contagieux ce qui ne semble pas être le
cas des plus petits est-ce que là dessus
vous avez vous même en tant qu enseigner
au fil des ans les directeurs d'école
est-ce que vous avez des informations ou
est ce que chacun dit un peu n'importe
quoi des informations je les ai je les
ai donné on ne peut pas dire on ne peut
pas dire qu'il ait pas de cas ce qui qui
s'avère dans les écoles on a un nombre
de cas qui est grandissant là au fil des
jours maintenant c'est plus en terme de
gestion j'imagine que c'est très
compliqué de pouvoir organiser les
choses au niveau des collèges bon au
niveau des lycées on est encore sur un
autre mode d'organisation
quoi qu'il en soit il faut il me semble
le bon sens veut que l'on soit prudent
aujourd'hui par rapport à ça mais même
si on a un certain nombre de réflexions
encore aujourd'hui sur la qualité des
moyens qui sont mis à disposition sur le
mode d'organisation qui peut y avoir il
faut être très prudent par rapport à
tout ça tout en sachant que je ne veux
pas qu'on puisse penser une seule
seconde que nous ne sommes pas attachés
au maintien des écoles à l'ouverture des
écoles c'est bien évident que
l'ouverture des écoles elle est
primordiale
il faut faire en sorte de ne pas creuser
davantage les inégalités sociales on
peut avoir il faut qu'on puisse
permettre aux élèves de poursuivre des
apprentissages
il faut qu'on puisse leur permettre de
maintenir un lien entre eux mais tout ça
ne pourra être possible que si la
sécurité scolaire dans les
établissements est garanti au quotidien
et qu'elle s'accompagne d'une priorité
nationale dans ce sens là je vous ai
posé la question parce que encadrent
confinement il ya une hypothèse qui dit
qu'en effet les collèges et les lycées
pourraient être fermées mais que les
écoles pourraient continuer à être
ouverte et ça impliquerait peut-être
alors ce que ce que vous dites c'est
zircon qu'on prenne soin des enseignants
collègues pour les qu'on les mette dans
les listes
prioritaires pour être vaccinés ici on
doit laisser les écoles ouvertes et on
comprend l'enjeu social de laisser les
écoles ouvertes parce que ça permet aux
enfants aux parents de travailler
beaucoup plus que six autres des enfants
dont ils doivent s'occuper dans ce cas
là c'est vrai que votre vos
revendications prennent tout leur sens
même vous m'entendez oui à de pardon non
je disais c'est un peu c'est un peu ce
que j'essaie de vous expliquer depuis le
départ c'est à dire que moi moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut essayer de faire
en sorte que les écoles restent ouvertes
clairement maintenant il faut rassurer
tout le monde par rapport à ça et en
tout premier lieu rassurer des personnes
de tous les partenaires et toutes les
personnes qui au quotidien font en sorte
que ces écoles puissent être ma plus
ouverte
florence woerth est né ce qu'est une
réaction à côté parce qu'on prend
parfaitement à ses revendications
d'autant plus que on voit bien vos
questions et vos réponses mathieu à
cacher c'est que vous êtes dans le flou
artistique avec des hommes contre ordre
et ça a commencé à dès le mois de
septembre
gérer à la rentrée et c'est vrai qu'il
faut soutenir au maximum les enseignants
d'autant plus qu'on sait pas très bien
sur ce nouveau virus mutant il pourrait
d'après ce que des informations de
scientifiques qui pourraient aussi
atteindre les enfants les enfants pour
être porteur même plus petits pour être
porteurs de ce virus
donc compte tenu un peu du flou dans
lequel nous sommes tous en mai vous plus
particulièrement des enfants et avec
cette cette obligation sociale qui est
de maintenir les écoles ouvertes en ce
qu'il faut que vous ayez un soutien
total que ce soit des municipalités mais
manifester leur ministère et j'avoue que
je suis un peu interloqué de savoir que
vous manquez de passe
et il me semble que dans certaines
écoles les enfants qui sont deux
familles les plus à l'est plus pauvres
ont des masques gratuits à l'école je
vous trouve enfin s'ils ont des masques
gratuits à l'école on a des masques à
destination des enfants
on a également une dotation de masques à
destination des enfants mais on nous a
bien d'expliquer que ces masques là
était destiné avant tout à fait au
quotidien si vous voulez à faire en
sorte qu'un enfant qui viendrait à
l'école sans masque puissent en
bénéficier mais on est sur des dotations
qui dans l'ensemble sont assez pauvres
par rapport à ça donc c de c c'est très
compliqué il me semble en tout cas que
l'intervention que je suis en train de
faire là les destinées aussi a expliqué
qu' il est nécessaire d'être très
prévoyants par rapport à tout ça et il
faut pas qu'on ait une multiplication de
cas qui à un moment donné pourrait
mettre l'école et des enfants et des
familles dans une beaucoup plus rare
qu'elle n'est aujourd'hui on arrive à
gérer les choses mais il faut vraiment
qu'on puisse que pour vous nous donner
les moyens nécessaires pour que tout le
monde soit tranquilliser et un peu plus
sereins par rapport à cette situation
côté merci merci beaucoup aux
roughriders en fera le point dans les
jours qui viennent justement peut-être
si jamais il ya ce confinement
l'ouverture des écoles ou pas ça c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre votre produit
merci beaucoup je t'ai cache un jeu vous
en bonne continuation merci on va
changer de sujet on va c'est lui et si
je veux dire on va partir dans l'espace
avec le lancement du vécu
sat qui est parti donc dimanche voilà il
est dans l'espace à la fenice qu temps
on va revenir d'abord sur ce lancement
qui avait été reporté deux ou trois fois
pour des raisons météorologiques ans
essentiellement c'est ça il ya eu
plusieurs petits soucis et donc voilà le
contenu de l'enjeu c'est quelque chose
de quoi être ma habituel on fait
attention à avoir toutes les pires
conditions pour mais c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'il est même des
autres bouteilles dans l'espace comme
vous faut maintenant il ya des
embouteillages leur look là là c'est
clair maintenant cesse c'est un record
du nombre de ces la réforme leamy dans
l'espace et donc bien évidemment c'était
aussi ça la peau la nouveauté il fallait
être certain que les choses se déroulent
dans le bon ordre pour éviter que voilà
les les isles d'autres se cogne et
finalement que ça se passe bien quoi
donc une nouvelle excuse est parti
dimanche lancé par space x on voit ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est ça alors là
j'avoue que j'ai parvient vraiment ils
étaient bâties tourne autour la terre
afin que pour ceux qui ont suivi un
petit peu la mise en orbite sur youtube
on voit que ça va très vite un 27 mille
kilomètres bomba
vous vous êtes vous le suivez pas comme
ça ils passent dans tout les trucs je
sais pas tout compris non plus mais vous
avez de lancer un satellite c'est ça non
c'est non ok je suis regardé au début en
effet il y à un satellite qui étaient
conçus et voulue et par le latmos qui
est le laboratoire qui s'occupe de
l'espace dont philippe qui écoute et le
directeur adjoint et écoute est à
l'origine avec d'autres chercheurs
évidemment de de ce satellite est ce
satellite qui est homme nos satellites
on va y revenir a été lancée dimanche
dans l'espace depuis cap canaveral par
là parce p 6 1 c'est ça non deuxième
raison c'est vrai que retient comme nous
on avait déjà parlé
on peut peut-être peu mais appeler les
gencives alors donc là tout va bien
alors il y avait effectivement plusieurs
étapes qui sont toujours critique
l'une d'elles outre le lancement était
la mise à poste 243 satellite avec des
gros et des plus petits est donc là
c'était donc le lancement se poser à 16
heures nos antennes se sont déployés à
normalement à 17h15 et à 17h30 les
amateurs ont commencé à essayer de
regarder si détecter le satellite ce qui
a été le cas et puis à 20 heures il
pâtit il passait au dessus de lui en
cours et donc ont récupéré les données
d'accord on voit les images la vue du
lancement
pendant que pendant que vous parlez
alors c'est un anneau satellite c'est
dire qu'il a il a quoi la taille d'un
rubik's cube on disait à peu près tout à
fait alors en fait les nano satellites
peuvent avoir différentes tailles en
fait qu'on les appelle aussi souvent qu
puis ça comme ça parce que ça correspond
un standard qui a été mis en place par
les américains et qui permet du coup de
minimiser les difficultés dans port
c'est à dire que du coup comme ses
standards ça rentre dans un tube qui a
la taille qui a toujours la même taille
et puis on en voit beaucoup la noue dans
alors il y en avait 143 nous on était
dans une partie où il y en avait 2 17
qui avait à peu près dé taille similaire
et donc on était on était le 14ème si je
me souviens bien de ses 17 à sortir et
donc on sort tous les uns à la queue leu
leu et donc ses interfaces sont beaucoup
plus simples et c'est ce qui participe
avec d'autres éléments à baisser le coût
il cette idée c'est ça qui finalement
est un peu la révolution c'est que du
coup cet accès à l'espace devient
beaucoup plus démocratique
on sait à peu près quel est le coût d'un
d'un cube soit là alors ça peut ça peut
ça peut varier
parce que là nous on en voit quelque
chose qui est relativement petit on peut
on peut faire plus grand avec des
fonctionnalités plus compliqué c'est ce
qui sera prévu dans les vins dans un
second temps est donc là disons qu'on
estime alors c'est toujours compliqué
parce que il faut faire des coups
consolidé on estime à peu près à 3
millions le le satellite en comptant les
heures de travail des personnels
donc autant aussi les salaires le
salaire des gens les infrastructures etc
le lancement lui-même se spécifie fait
vraiment baisser les coûts par rapport à
d'autres solutions c'est ce que fait il
ça vraiment aujourd'hui celle c'est le
moins cher est finalement
l'une partie de la baisse de ses coûts
c'est le fait que du coup ou partie des
états sont récupérées c'est ça aussi
c'était une partie très très
impressionnante c'est vous avez une
barge
il récupère un étage et qui va très
utilisé donc du coup effectivement on
voit on voit le modèle qui est qui est
tout à fait économiquement intéressant
c'est à dire pour ça que ça a été de
lancer de cap canaveral par ego de
course est bon d'abord il faut dire à
quoi va servir ce satellite alors ce
satellite là il va regarder
les émissions qui viennent de la terre
et qui viennent du soleil alors
principalement pour répondre aux
questions de la problématique du
changement climatique en fait tout le
monde connaît effectivement que les gaz
à effet de serre augmentent mais en fait
l'équilibré dia tiff et changements de
température est dû aux émissions va
plutôt à l'absorption du rayonnement
solaire
c'est un équilibre leur alignement
solaire et l'émission infrarouge de la
terre des nuages et aider et des gaz à
effet de serre et donc lorsqu'on observe
çà on voit qu elle l déséquilibre parce
que dans cet équilibre là bien
évidemment il ya les gaz à effet de
serre qui joue mais vous avez aussi
l'albédo cyr la réflexion des sols qui
est très importante donc déforestation
diminution de la glace la glace et c'est
donc c'est à tous et nous c'était une
mesure qu'il peut se faire que depuis
l'espace et qui permet de faire cet
équilibre et de et de compléter les
mesures qu'on a déjà
en donnant une réponse sur le
déséquilibre le revenant à st 2
satellite s'occupe satellite
scientifiquement c'est une prouesse de
faire quelque chose de l'allant petit
oui alors d'aider le laboratoire n'avait
jamais les jacks aussi désastreux mort
et passionné l'envoya vraiment on a des
instruments qui aujourd'hui roule sur le
rover martien
on était dans l' aventure aux étapes bon
donc pour pour nous faire des
instruments spatiaux cessé de quotidien
de l'hymne du laboratoire là ce qui est
un petit peu nouveau c'est que
effectivement alors pour pour pour
correspondre
aux contraintes économiques il faut
faire petit pour pouvoir effectivement
en envoyer des satellites moins cher
plus rapidement et c est donc là il
fallait il fallait regrouper dans un
cube beaucoup beaucoup de choses et là
c'était compliqué oui parce qu'il faut
tout miniaturisés et ce n'est pas que
miniaturisés on a aussi la problématique
du spatial qu'il faut qu'on soit certain
que ça fonctionne continue des
investissements et donc il faut tester
les choses et récupérer le plus possible
des choses qui ont déjà été prouvée
alors c'est comme ça que fonctionne le
spatial ce qu'il ya c'est que jusqu'à
présent on fonctionnait une échelle
alors fonctionne à une échelle plus
petite et donc il faut redévelopper
l'ensemble des concepts
sur cette échelle qui est plus petit
alors bien évidemment les américains ont
lancé cette stratégie depuis longtemps
donc ils ont ils ont déjà des
entreprises qui proposent des choses qui
ont été validés dans l'espace donc on
peut réutiliser et mais mais mais mais
ce
il faut qu'on prenne notre place dans ce
secteur aussi bien raison parce que dans
les bars dont c'est un satellite et une
durée de vie est faite d'exploitation
très longue
c'est alors la place à celui là c'est le
premier ça va être un prototype parce
que pour nous ce qui est tout à fait
nouveau c'est c'est de s'occuper de
l'ensemble serre que habituellement
s'occuper de l'instrument ne s'occupait
pas de la plate forme donc là
aujourd'hui on se trouvait s'est occupé
de la plateforme s'occuper des problèmes
de récupération des données donc donc
c'est un petit peu nouveau pour nous
donc a priori il ya toujours beaucoup
d'aléatoire dans le domaine spatial donc
a priori je dirais que si durait trois
ans ce serait ce sera une période très
bien venue d un petit nous verrait
beaucoup et qui démontrerait vraiment la
pertinence si c'est un an ça permet de
faire un cycle annuel
c'est déjà bien et puis de toute façon
toutes les données qui seront acquis
seront seront utilisés et réutilisées
souvent on a 10 ans 20 ans a exposé
l'état on descend on en tire le maximum
jusqu'au bout l ajustement lancement ça
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle le new
space c'est à dire qu'une évolution au
fond de la conquête spatiale c'est vrai
qu'on a eu les grandes avancées avec
l'homme qui marche sur les lieux de cet
état ont l'impression que là on est au
valais plus tôt peut-être vers de la
robotisation vers des machines qui vont
dans l'espace plutôt que des hommes ccsa
le new space alors le new space c'est
beau chacun sa définition indigne ou
space un petit peu disons que c'est
surtout le fait que vous avez des
acteurs nouveaux et donc
traditionnellement
bon nous nous on travaille avec notre
agence spatiale qui est le cnes notre
agence spatiale européenne qui les a
depuis longtemps et donc pour nous le
spatial c'est pas nouveau ce qui est
nouveau aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement on multiplie nombre
d'acteurs veiller à 143 satellites y
sont partis ça avec un seul annonceurs
et donc et donc beaucoup beaucoup de
monde maintenant puisque comme si comme
il ya une démocratisation
vous avez plein de pays qui n'avaient
pas d'argent spatiale qui aujourd'hui
accède à l'espace et donc du fait qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'acteurs les règles
changent puisque avant vous aviez une
dizaine d'agents spatiale qui se
mettaient d'accord entre elles sur un
certain nombre de règles cette somme de
programme aujourd'hui vous en avez
beaucoup beaucoup et donc du coup vous
avez des questions nouvelles qui
apparaissent d'une exceptionnelle sur la
partie juridique sur la partie
économique qui va être différents
endroits de l'espace de l'espace et donc
tout ça fait fait qu' on est on est dans
une ère du cou qui étaient étaient
nouvelle puisque physiquement on a on a
beaucoup d'interlocuteurs et donc nous
qui défendons la partie scientifique de
l'espace le fait d'y accéder pour
pouvoir pour amener des nouvelles
données on est dans un cadre où on
collabore avec nos collègues de tous les
pays comme on le fait sur les autres
domaines scientifiques espèrent qu'elle
est choquée vous allez vous spécialisé
en droit de l'espace qu'ils fassent
entendre à 10 passes et puis c'est un
nouveau domaine notamment totalement
fasciné par l'espace des expériences et
vous parliez certitude l'environnement
et la problématique du climat sur la
terre mais j'ai cru comprendre aussi que
l'espace devenue une poubelle et qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'objets d'objets volants
qu'il faudrait récupérer et est-ce que
voilà est-ce qu'il y a des des engins
qui sont là pour faire camions poubelles
entre guillemets dans l'espace alors en
fait comme partout c'est il faut il faut
le gérer c'est à dire que en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que tous les objets qui
sont qui tourne autour de l'espace un
moment donné reviennent sur terre et
donc en traversant l'atmosphère se
désagrège et donc très très une petite
poussière mais je dirais de la même
manière que le font les météorites qui
nous arrive en permanence donc ça ça
n'est pas un problème ce kit est un
problème c'est effectivement notamment
les débris ou comme on l'a vu des
explosions qui crée alors la plein plein
de débris parce que là chaque débris
menaçait les autres donc à une il ya un
effectivement une gestion de ces débris
pour éviter que finalement on en voit
une plateforme très importante très cher
qui va servir à la télé à la
télécommunication à la météo et qui soit
détruit détruite par parle est un petit
objet dont on a besoin de gérer alors
aujourd'hui
côté français il ya une réglementation
qui est très clair vous n'acceptez pas
n'importe quelle heure bits et est donc
le nous mêmes nous avons accédé à une
orbite qui qui qui fait qu'on va très
très rapidement finalement retombé et
donc ne pas créer de 2,2
de problèmes et de déchets et et ses
réglementations vont se durcir et il est
clair que et on l'a bien vu il ya un
certain nombre de plateformes qui était
doté qui ont été mises en orbite qui a
plus haute orbite qui sont dotés de
moteurs qui leur permet effectivement
d'accélérer cette désorbitation dire que
dès qu'un système n'est plus opérant
dans l'espace effectivement on voit bien
qu'il faut nettoyer alors ceci n'a pas
été le cas toujours et puis on a entendu
parler de ces petits problèmes
géopolitiques ou des ducs ou d'aider
certains démontré leur puissance en
faisant exploser des certains objets
donc ça c'est catastrophique
et donc ces objets là par contre il faut
trouver un moyen aussi pour l'épauler
pour les enlever quoi et parce que
souvent c'est ça peut être un tout petit
objet à une bille dans l'espace ça vous
détruit un satellite
donc il faut il arriver à l'ére détruits
il y avait alors autre question qui est
intéressante et importante on parlait de
new space vous avez été lancé par space
x
mais dès la conception et d pour le
financement de ce nouveau satellite
il ya eu une coopération du public et du
privé sauf si c'est assez nouveau
ah oui oui alors en fait ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que malgré tout aujourd'hui
on se réjouit et puis là on a des
données donc je pense que que la
communauté scientifique va se saisir ces
zones et va être très intéressé quand on
a commencé on n'était pas beaucoup à y
croire à part quelques-uns qui peut-être
y voyait un démonstrateur technologique
la partie scientifique des petits
satellites personne n'y croyait donc on
a démarré ce projet vraiment de manière
très très différente des autres sert
qu'on l'a démarré sans équipe sans
financement sans rien on n'était que
quelques-uns y croire et petit à petit
les gens ont commencé à comprendre que
ça allait être créée et qu'on allait
vous avez trouvé aux foulées black v ner
centenaire de partenaires sont venus et
comme on avait par ailleurs parce que ça
n'est pas vrai que dans le public
développé une forte logique de
partenariat public privé
alors on a trouvé des partenaires
historiques qui nous ont aidés
mais c'est pas simple c'est pas simple
parce que aujourd'hui c'est pas dans le
futur c'est toujours pas dans la culture
parce qu'on en parle beaucoup mais rien
n'est fait pour le faciliter c'est à
dire que là on a besoin quand même au
plus haut niveau de l'état que les
règles changent parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde dit il faut qu'il faut que
le public et privé travaillent ensemble
sur la recherche mais mais au quotidien
c'est pas le cas parce que c'est un
casse-tête et les procédures ne sont pas
là et tout est fait pour pour nous pour
nous en dissuader
c'est vrai qu'on retrouve un peu
toujours la lourdeur administrative dans
une autre
le millefeuille le fameux millefeuille
administratif vont terminer sur ce sujet
la france était un des grands pays
d'auray est un des grands pays de
l'espace
évidemment il est des états unis et
l'urss autour de la guerre froide il
acheminera ensuite la france et dans les
tout premiers pays c'est ça reste une
priorité la conquête spatiale pour
l'heure pour la france alors en tout cas
c'est bien sûr parce que finalement
quand vous regardez notre agence
spatiale nationale le cnes
l une qui a acquis qui met en orbite un
grand grand nombre d'instruments pour la
science donc que d'eau pour nous
scientifiques
c'est très important ce qui est c'est
que ce qu'on voit apparaître c'est
effectivement d'autres façons de faire
donc il faut c'était un peu ça aussi
pour nous l'enjeu c'est qu'il faut il
faut aussi se renouveler et est à côté
de ses missions qui vont rester parce qu
on a on a aussi besoin de grosses
missions il ya des choses qui sont d'un
point de vue physique immuable c'est à
dire que si vous voulez observer le ciel
vous pouvez pas faire avec un petit
télescope pour forcément un grotesque et
vous avez beau être capable d'envoyer un
anneau sade vous n'en verrez pas vous
n'observez pas le ddd des galaxies
lointaines à partir d'un rubik's cube
c'est pas possible d'obtenir des
principes physiques que vous ne pourrez
pas faire mais il ya de la place
enfin il faut que le que la france
prenne sa place aussi sur ce secteur qui
est tout à fait complémentaires et
permet aussi une recherche dynamique
parce que du coup on l'a bien vu
développement en deux ans d'un nano
satellites ça veut dire que nos
scientifiques on est capable de tester
des choses d'avoir des premiers
premières réponses dont on voit bien
face aux à l'urgence climatique aux
problématiques de métérologie qu'il faut
gérer et qu'il faut gérer en urgence
on a besoin d'outils et donc les nanos
sat peuvent compléter ce qui existe déjà
et permettent d'apporter des réponses
en tout cas c'est une belle réussite
c'est ubs cussac bravo bravo parce que
c'est vrai que vous avez commencé comme
nous le dit un peu seul voilà même si
maintenant tout le monde vient au
secours du succès on va parler de notre
cinéma on va pas de si loin que ça c'est
la phrase de d'emmanuel macron
sommes-nous 66 millions de procureur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est oui c'est intéressant parce
qu'il constitue presque avec vous parce
qu'il s'adressait à des étudiants
scientifiques
justement en redisant sa et di au fond
chacun fait des erreurs sauf celui qui
ne cherchent pas où il refait tous les
jours est la même chose et justement le
principe de la fleur c'est justement de
parfaire tous les jours la même chose et
de prendre des risques c'est ça qu'il
faut prendre et il faut pas avoir peur
de l'échec ccc c'est vrai que ces
futures un peu française que qu'on a du
mal à abandonner alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu alors il se fera sur les gaulois
réfractaires il ya la fameuse phrase de
de gaulle on peut pas gouverner un pays
qu'il ya deux cent cinquante huit sortes
de fromages
il ya c'est vrai une plainte habituel
quoi des gouvernants sur l'attitude des
français c'est pas nous c'est pas très
nouveau mais ce qui est un peu nouveau
avec le président macron c7
et qui semble partagé par son premier
ministre c'est qu'on n'a plus le droit
de les critiquer ses terres que dès
qu'il ya une début d'opposition et dieu
sait s'ils ont de la chance l'opposition
entend tellement consternante qui ne
sont pas très dérangés par là mais dès
qu'il ya une voie un peu dissonante tout
de suite c'est avec ce n'est pas
constructif ne faisait pas loin de dire
du mal de ce qu'on fait on ne devait pas
le droit de douter
il faut lutter contre l'asthme non on a
le droit on est français on a le droit
de donner notre avis on a le droit de ne
pas être d'accord avec la politique du
président salah remet pas en cause il a
été élu démocratiquement
mais qu'il arrête comme ça de de
critiquer tout le monde et 66 millions
de procurant des 66 millions d'électeurs
sur tout enfin pas 66 millions mais bon
on vote pour les livres qu'elle veut de
leurs meetings
il faut arrêter d'infantiliser les
français il faut arrêter de les prendre
pour des crétins et sur tous ces points
les injuriant dans 66 millions de
procurer alors oui on a le droit mais
badoc dans sa bouche oui c'en était une
blanc ce mercredi choqué alors je trouve
ça un peu radicale de dire 66 millions
procureur parce que procureur ça
voudrait dire qu'on est tous deux
critiques et je pense qu'il ya deux
catégories de catégories de personnes
via les gens qui sont des répétiteurs
donc c'est probablement un peu sont des
gens qui sont pas très créatif et puis
avec créateurs et je pense que c'est
vis-à-vis des créateurs peut-être qu'il
servit niamey a justement tous ceux qui
sont créatifs les gens fous peuvent
effectivement être force de proposition
derrière la critique alors le problème
c'est que certains français parce que je
pense qu'on peut pas dire tous les
français mais à certains français ont
tendance à quoi qu'il arrive à critiquer
avoir un avis sur tout y compris des
avis sur lesquels des scientifiques donc
je vois arriver à dépasser de passer
cette attitude là cette posture et il
faudrait qu'ils gens prennent l'habitude
aussi de ne plus écouter les autres pour
se faire son avis il alors voilà les
matticks idées à des réseaux sociaux
basson 50 avis à la minute
je suis en dessous et à mal à la
réflexion et au dépassement des avis
tout fait et il ya donc une réflexion
alors il ya peut-être une part aussi de
responsabilité d'être aussi des médias
des réseaux sociaux mais aussi des
médias où il ya peu de médias ou viable
la réflexion pour faire avancer les avis
des uns des autres à 66 millions d'euros
terreur je trouve ça un peu c'est un peu
vrai mais ça fait partie des phrases
aussi un peu tout faire et radicale du
matin c'est une référence 66 millions de
sélectionneurs donc parlé à raymond
domenech
il ya un mot s'est passé houleux que de
l'ultra crépy daria 10 mhz ça vous dit
quelque chose
alors c'est un tabou qui a été remis en
vogue par un philosophe et scientifique
qui etienne klein et l'ultra crépy
d'ariane servir d'une expression latine
qui disait cordonnier pas plus haut que
la chaussure et ça veut dire c'est cette
façon quand même de parler avec beaucoup
d'assurance de ce qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est comme tu répondes vaut le
scientifique que vous êtes derrière c
est ce que vous regardez cette période
avec étonnement sion tout le monde a un
avis sur le vaccin sur la façon de
soigner le virus est ce que vous pensez
pas qu'on devrait quand même laissé ou
laisser des gens qui savent parler ou se
taire un petit peu quand on ne sait pas
et il y avait cette phrase fabuleuse de
tous les hommes politiques on a entendu
je ne suis pas médecin mais je pense que
l'hydro chloroquine enfin je ne suis pas
médecin mais moi j'ai par exemple
absolument aucun avis bien évidemment
scientifique n'est médicale sur le
vaccin comment il faut l'administré s'il
faut faire 5 ou 6 go aux éclats
mais on a le droit en tant que citoyen
quand même de donner son avis sur notre
vie et la politique et la façon dont on
peut les mener
alors
droit sur la politique c'est après c'est
vrai qu'on entend beaucoup de gens dire
mais il faudrait tester tel tel
traitement alors qu'ils sont pas
absolument incompétent oui mais on peut
par exemple être tout à fait perplexe en
disant on nous impose par exemple ce
confinement qui va venir ces gestes
barrière c'est ces fermetures de
restaurants ne va plus loin en disant il
faut sauver services de santé parce que
sinon le service de santé va être
obligés de se mettre à trier les malades
quand ils vont arriver alors le tri des
malades c'est une catastrophe
mais qu'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire avec le vaccin autre idée au tri
des malades les futurs malades puisque
on a honte rit on dit seulement 75 ans
est arrêté voilà donc le tri dans un
sens on nous dit qu'il est bien puis
dans l'autre sens ce serait pas bien
c'est totalement contradictoire donc le
cheval procureur mais j'ai droit d'avoir
un avis là dessus j'ai le droit d'avoir
aussi un à dix on est toujours en train
de nous dire surtout faut jamais mettre
un militaire ou à la tête du ministère
des armées parce que ça choquerait tout
le monde un général à la on dirait voilà
c'est une catastrophe
et puis là nous on met un médecin à la
santé mais c'est exactement pareil c'est
une cc la même catastrophe mais
expliquez moi la différence
un médecin à la santé ou un général au
ministère des armées ça n'a pas de sens
ça n'a pas de sens les fameuses phases
la guerre est trop sérieuse pour être
confiée à des généraux c'est exact et je
pense que la crise sanitaire est trop
sérieuse pour être confiée un médecin il
faut réhabiliter notre une constituante
ils ont l'impression que nous ne sommes
plus gouverné il ya plus de gouvernement
il ya des médecins qui ont pris le
pouvoir des autorités diverses et
variées qui nous disent alors le masque
en tissu le masque non le masque que oui
le confinement va arriver et macro et et
castex concrètement disparu l'impression
qu'ils attendent que le professeur
diafoirus qui doit leur téléphoner le
matin d'hier bon alors qu'un manuel g on
n'a qu'à confient les bains d'accord on
confie la politique et disparus plus qu
un conseil de défense et inconsciente
ific qui conseille fana mais vous devez
pas inventé non plus je n'ai pas cité
total
je pense que le rôle du politique c'est
de prendre conseil auprès des experts
mais de faire de la politique il n'en
fait plus de la politique on ne fait que
de la santé alors moi je ne suis pas
expert en santé mais je voudrais que les
politiques reprennent le pouvoir
je n'ai pas voté pour le professeur
delfraissy j'ai voté pour le président
macron voilà donc je voudrais que ce
soit lui qui gouverne et faim et
médecins se heurte à des seuils ne suis
pas du tout d'accord avec jean charles
d'une part sur la notion de tri
heureusement qu'on vaccine les plus
fragiles qui pourrait effectivement ou
payer entre guillemets les les hôpitaux
ils sont fragiles et qui sont je crois
que c'est un tiers des morts sont dans
les ehpad et les personnes âgées
moi ça me choque pas du tout maxime
d'abord il s'agit pour voilà pour sauver
sauver leur chanter à partir de 75
mais ça ne choque pas du tout non plus
le tri mois mais aucun tri ne me choque
moi c'est donc ces normes cellulaires de
critiquer les prix de critiques jusque
là ont cessé mais c'est tout à fait
normal de deux priorités là et là je
pense que ce jeu ce choix de trine est
un choix politique c'est pas qu'un choix
scientifiques jeu je pense je pense que
heureusement
heureusement que monsieur manquerait de
scientifiques parce qu'il ne l'est pas
et joueurs en quoi le peut
de prendre des décisions comme ça s'il
n'est pas entouré du cefic john qui
donne une ligne
en tout cas médical sur ce qui se passe
c'est quelque chose qui est une grande
première depuis puis des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années en france qui fait
quand même beaucoup de morts on voit la
courbe repartent à la hausse
et heureusement qu'il ya des gens s'y
fier qui lui donne les données
scientifiques après c'est à lui de
décider le politique de savoir ce qu'on
applique qui compte actuellement en
terme de confinement confinement
régionales nationales départementales
voilà ça c'est une décision politique
lorsqu'on fils pas écrire en pas de
décision politique
la place justement des scientifiques
comme conseiller du pouvoir c à 6 c à
ccc ça me semble important c'est nous
nous nous nous apprendre à nos étudiants
d'être critique d'eau que c'est pas les
gars veut dire que les gens doivent pas
parler il faut il faut il faut il faut
être critique il faut il faut il faut
réfléchir après le mécanisme
scientifique il est il est à mon avis on
croise les doigts il et il est très bon
c'est à dire que les gens se ce parce
que sur des fêtes que leurs homologues
critique avec aussi des faits et et
c'est cette controverse écrite et
validées qui à la fin abouti finalement
un consensus
alors les difficultés viennent toujours
quand le politique doit prendre une
décision plus rapidement que ce que le
chercheur peut faire alors on a le même
problème sur le climat on voudrait des
longues séries de données pour se dire
est ce qu on mesure bien tout est ce
qu'on comprend bientôt donc il ya un
problème climatique c'est évident mais
après oui pour pour le gérer il va
falloir comprendre quels sont les les
acteurs et donc on a besoin d'
observation mais le politique il nous
presse et des fois du coup on contraint
le scientifique à dire un peu des
bêtises parce que il a fallu
complètement fermé son étude le temps
politique le ton médiatique le temps
scientifique cette main tendue
voilà les deux couches je partage
effectivement la vie que qu'un moment
et c'est aux politiques avec les
informations les meilleurs qui l'a qui
doit prendre une décision
elle est bonne elle est pas bonne c'est
son rôle après 2 de prendre la bonne
direction et d'être un peu intuitif ou
de de sortir les choses mais mais mais
mais il faut pas mélanger je suis assez
d'accord les scientiques x doit avoir
les moyens avoir le temps pour fournir
des données et ça arrive quand ça arrive
et là dessus politique doit doit doit
doivent faire un choix
corrigé son choix si finalement les
données changent et c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a une situation qui
était compliqué cccc que c'est
complètement nouveau ces crises là et du
coup la politique est obligé en
permanence de réactualiser il faut
qu'ils s'expriment malgré tout je pense
pour que les choses soient claires un
mot sur justement le duvet excuse sat
réchauffement climatique
on entend parler d'un référendum
fin d'année fin si tout va bien c'est
pas sûr que les procédures puissent se
puisse arriver de référendum dans lequel
sera inscrit dans la constitution la
république garantit la préservation de
la biodiversité de l'environnement et
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
c'est important je pense pour pour nous
tous pour les générations futures
est ce que justement la procédure de
référendum ça risque pas de biaiser un
peu cette question d'en faire une
question politique on va voter pour ou
contre celui qui pose la question c'est
très bien comment se fasse un référendum
ou est ce que c'est important au
contraire que les gens prennent en
compte cette cet impératif selon vous
bon moi ce soir devant domaines de
compétences notre un casque ce qui ce
qui est ce qui me paraît assez clair
c'est que aujourd'hui il faut du courage
politique c'est à dire que les outils on
les a on voit pas pourquoi effectivement
aujourd'hui on met pas un prix à la
pollution qui permettrait effectivement
docteur de résoudre ces problèmes et
donc c'est ça qu'on attend c'est que
finalement aujourd'hui on ne puissent
pas acheter à un prix dérisoire
un produit qui aura transité dalle
d'amérique du sud alors qu'il va la
saison et c'est donc il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses que l'on peut faire
aujourd'hui pour ralentir ces problèmes
là sont forcément il me semble avoir de
nouveau
voilà de l'inscrire dans la constitution
ou dans de faire des outils juridiques
et des textes constituent pour moi on en
est on en est au courage politique
d'aller dans la bonne direction
on va passer aux terres parce qu'il ne
reste plus beaucoup de temps mais je
voudrais quand même qu'on parle un peu
de la caricature et de est ce que est ce
qu'on peut-on rire de tout et comment et
avec qui celle de la vieille ville
question mais qui se repose de façon
de temps à autre je connaissais bien les
dessinateurs bah oui oui sans dépublié
beaucoup aller on a failli publié gorce
les deux ex dessinateur du monde du
monde alors c'est un des cinq été
publiés sur la sphère duhamel voilà et
il fait des pingouins kaki dialogues
souvent danser dans ses dessins et si
j'ai été abusé par le demi frère adoptif
de la compagne de mon père transgenres
devenu ma mère est ce un inceste demandé
un mois à l'autre et ça a provoqué une
suite de réactions notamment de deux
personnes transgenres qui ont vu une
agression le monde s'est excusé le
dessinateur dorce trouvé que c'était
excuses étaient déplacés les placer et
il a démissionné du monde
voilà je pense qu'il a eu totalement
raison c'est d'ailleurs toujours
courageux de démissionner tong et
dessinateur d'un quotidien critiquable
certes mais enfin indispensable puis
extrêmement important que le monde donc
c'est quand même quitter une tribune
importante ce quoi ce qui lui a déplu et
non seulement les excuses mais en fait
le ton même des excuses qui dit nous
n'aurions pas dû publier ce dessin le
propre du dessin de presse et c'est une
spécificité un peu qui va devenir
française parce que les américains
abandonnent le dessin de presse
justement à cause des dépressions parce
que dès qu'un dessinateur faisait
quelque chose il ya un groupe de 8 2 2
jean qui dira non non ça nous choque ça
nous ça nous dérange etc
c'est un espace de liberté et faut
arrêter bien évidemment la question que
vous posiez est-ce qu'on peut rire de
tout oui on peut rire de tout tout le
temps et pas en choisissant les gens
avec lequel on a envie de rire
sinon c'est la fin je veux dire il ya
deux thèses qui s'opposent il ya caroni
forest et natacha polony par exemple qui
dénote une dérive moraliste inquiétante
pour la liberté d'expression
et si on lit mediapart de l'autre côté
estiment que la liberté d'expression
brandie par gorce et ses soutiens ne
justifie pas des attaques systématiques
contre les victimes d'agressions et et
contre ceux et celles qui se battent
pour un monde plus juste
enfin l'or alors on pourrait pas de rire
voilà deux de ça enfin mediapart il
ferait mieux de s'occuper je veux pas
balancé le nom d des professeurs qui
qui s'intéresse à la liberté
d'expression sur la place publique
plutôt que de s'attaquer à gorce
voilà donc on ouvre une autre descendant
tracé assez boudy vivement que l'on est
un média qui nous disent la vérité comme
on veut qu'elle soit fait et très
honnêtement tous les dessins degorce
alors après bien évidemment c'est que
monaco n'est pas blessé quand un type de
grand talent qui a beaucoup d'humour
très fin et puis et là en plus il faut
arrêter un petit peu ce qu'est ce que
les trans gens viennent se mêler de ça
il ya le mot 30 ans à lundi on sent
attaqué mais je veux dire mais ça
devient ridicule ridicule maintenant
qu'il ya une moralisation plus fort dans
la société
l'ajout de la sortir encore de votre
donner un avis tout à fait personnel qui
n'engage que moi mais moi je pense que
bon dans le débat de savoir si fou rire
surtout je je je voudrais pas avancer
cela étant je pense que il faut qu'on
parle de beaucoup de choses dire que les
tabous svo jamais de bons et il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on ne parle pas
assez
et du coup on n'en parle pas assez et
c'est ça qui crée à mon avis des
problèmes alors après ben euh le
transgenre ccc cecon assez nouveau dans
notre débat assez probablement pas
nouveau donne dans la donne dans la
société ça déjà existé et on voit bien
que ça conduit à des difficultés de
vivre des uns et des autres donc moi je
crois qu'il faut en parler pour que les
gens sachent que ça existe et puis
puisse habituel c'est dans un autre
domaine c'est pareil pour le handicap le
cash on est tous sous le tapis et donc
c'est pas normal on doit vivre dans
cette société avec tout ce qui existe et
est trouvé que chacun trouve sa place et
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya eu une
période par exemple ou les handicapés et
d'été blessé quand il y avait des des
caricatures et après il ya eu une
évolution il manque d'être traités comme
les autres
seulement
c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être un moment
dans la société où les gens sont plus
sensibles que d'autres aux aux attaques
on va vous apte à courir même enfin ce
qui est adressée intéressant c'est que
l'on rit de plus en plus et le domaine
du risible est en train de se rétrécir
france alors moi je suis très choquée
que qu'il ait dû partir à du monde je
suis très choqué des excuses et du monde
parce que c'est pas dans cette phrase
c'est en fait tous les sujets qui
remuent la société aujourd'hui que ce
soit la sexualité en fait tout est dans
cette phrase que je trouve vraiment très
très bien vue sur les problèmes
familiaux a multiplié d'hier le lieu du
dessin c'est à dire de dire qu'est ce
que c'est un assassin c'est est ce que
c'est qu'un nas est acquis on pose la
problématique du transgenre ici enfin
tout est dit dans cette phrase je ne
comprends pas qu'elle a émis
effectivement ils prêteraient monde
venait très moraliste tapie dit bon et
c'est vraiment dommage
vous êtes l'avocate degorce donc merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup espèrent que des
chocs et merci beaucoup
vic écoutez donc on va suivre quand même
de l'évolution du s cussac dans l'est
dans les heures ou les jours qui
viennent merci beaucoup cherché à johnny
voilà on n'a pas eu trop le temps
donnant pas là on en reparlera le seul
témoin de jean-françois parce que ça se
passe en sibérie supériorité tout à fait
passionnant saisissant glaçant mais
c'est vrai si on peut en reparler très
grand roman
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup et à très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de boeuf
[Musique]